la ryder cup passé on pense déjà à la
suite dans les yvelines la fédération
française de golf la direction des
services de l'éducation nationale et les
élus ont inauguré lundi deux nouvelles
sections golf dans les collèges de
nouvelles classes qui répondent à la
logique de démocratisation de la
discipline lancée dès 2008 nous étions
un peu dans un paradoxe finalement dans
le département avec près de 32 sites
golfique et puis aucune section sportive
scolaire
donc aujourd'hui nous en sommes à deux
nous
comptons évidemment prolonger cette
dynamique le golfeur professionnel
français michaël lorenzo vera et le
parent de ces sections yvelinoise une
quarantaine de collégiens de tous les
niveaux peuvent dès à présent bénéficier
de trois heures de golf par semaine nos
athlètes et champion de golf de demain
sont là et lorsque je vois ces jeunes
naturellement avoir un bon swing de golf
taper dans la balle avec beaucoup de
naturel je suis contente
il découvre enfin notre sport avant d'en
faire des champions l'objectif est
surtout de démocratiser la pratique la
section sportive leur ouvre la voie à la
licence unss des heures d'entraînement
supplémentaire le mercredi pour les plus
motivés et des compétitions cdl qui dans
l'ensemble sont assez attentif et qui
ont envie de progresser parce que c'est
vraiment basée sur la motivation est
parti au moment où on l avait motivé je
veux dire il réussit plus vite que
n'importe quel autre élève l'éducation
nationale s'est fixé pour objectif
l'ouverture de 4000 sections sportives
supplémentaires dans toute la france
d'ici 2024